how'd he do everybody I'd like to
introduce myself my name is Ronald
Reagan a few months ago I was a sports
announcer on a radio station in Des
Moines Iowa one day I ran into one of
these movie talent scouts I think I
caught him off guard because the next
thing I knew I was taking a screen test
for Warner Brothers in Hollywood I guess
it was okay at least I liked Hollywood
so here I am hi Matt Welch for recent TV
I'm here in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest
and I'm joined by Mark Elliott author of
Reagan the Hollywood years who's giving
a presentation here at Freedom Fest so I
grew up in California
no Reagan a little bit the basic
caricature is that he was a B maybe C
actor who started a lot of chimp movies
how accurate is that that kind of a
basic take on my accurate yeah you know
he gets a big rap for a bedtime for
Bonzo everybody Johnny Carson lived off
of that film but actually it wasn't that
bad a movie if you ever saw it
Carrie granted one year earlier called
monkey business which didn't hurt Cary
Grant a career and let's not forget King
Kong so the monkey movies had their
place in Clint Eastwood a couple of our
anger tank films but reason the reason
Reagan got the rap was because he then
went into politics and it was an easy
target for the opposition to say this is
a guy who makes movies with monkeys so
the bedtime thing stayed with him one of
the problems for Regan at that time was
a he couldn't get a job he went into the
army drafted into the army I think in
1941 right after Pearl Harbor but didn't
go and see action he he made propaganda
movies for
Brothers which didn't help anybody I
mean they were good movies they kept him
working kept food on the table but when
the war ended and all the soldiers came
back who had been movie stars they they
found themselves out of work that they
were too old they were considered 30s
era movie actors because he couldn't get
a job he became increasingly interested
in the political side of Hollywood
politics had always interested him and
he started off as a standard-issue FDR
liberal is that so yeah it was a FDR
liberal because it was Depression years
he grew up in the Depression years and
he got a job in the Midwest
you know in Chicago outside of Chicago
and he got a job as a sportscaster which
was a big deal in those days he went to
California for spring training with the
Chicago Cubs and wound up meeting a girl
at the Roosevelt Hotel
she said take off those glasses you're
not that ugly and maybe I could talk to
somebody and get you a job as a next
door or something girl in that last
scene is Jim Travis
nice girl as I said before I think I'm
going to like Hollywood yeah he was
smitten by Hollywood like everybody was
and he became a utility man you know
there's a very famous story retold a
difference a thousand different ways but
the truth of it is that when Jack Warner
the head of Warner Brothers one of the
founding brothers heard that Ronald
Reagan was running for governor he said
Reagan for governor no no that's that's
wrong Errol Flynn for governor Reagan
for best friend and and that that I
think tells you how they thought of
Reagan and he was he was pigeon-holed as
the best friend as the pal as the
wholesome
not especially hot good kid from the
Midwest who filled in as the buddy for
all these rough-and-ready
hot actors like Flynn those kind of guys
but it was in politics in Hollywood that
he really found his calling
then when the mob moved into Hollywood
Al Capone sent his number-one guy Willie
by off to infiltrate Yahtzee take it
over and then go to the studios and say
look you don't want to strike this year
they up and we'll keep working that's
the way Hollywood operated Reagan was
scheduled to give a big speech at the
Hollywood Legion the night before he got
a phone call saying if you step out of
your house we're gonna throw acid in
your face Reagan being Reagan shot over
to Warner Brothers went in to Jack
Warner and said what should I do
Warner opened up the draw took out a gun
T here carry this these these Hollywood
guys they didn't know where the draw a
line between reality and who even knows
that the gun worked or something but
Reagan took it strapped it on a six-gun
and he felt that he was protected
because if these guys are going to come
after him he shoot two years later
Reagan is the president of the Screen
Actors Guild far more important than
that time for Bonzo and all these films
that were lying around 348 I had no
lives they were gathering dust in
warehouses and deteriorating who could
sell these to television and make a
fortune
because television eats programming and
needs content so all these local
stations 11 o'clock at night the twelve
o'clock at night baseball game rainout
the show a film make a fortune licensing
the movies and because the original
contracts were done as work for hire
these actors got paid salaries the
studio's own the film so when they sold
these movies
the Screen Actors Guild said wait a
minute you're making money on these
movies over and over again and our
actors aren't making anything we want a
piece of the action so that turned into
the first strike that SAG ever pulled on
Hollywood again aimed at Warner Brothers
always the big target and it was Reagan
who came in and settled a strike by
saying all right we'll draw the line at
1948 pre 1948
actors don't get paid because their
original contract was worked for hire
but after 1948 actors have to get
residuals and in order to sell that he
made all the producers put up I think it
was a four million dollar seed fund for
an actress pensions in 1950 actors like
Mickey Rooney and even Bob Hope who was
a great friend of Reagan were outraged
by this Bob Hope said every time I turn
on the television I'm seeing myself
entertaining people and I'm not making a
dime it's worse than horrible because a
zombie has no will of his own you see
them sometimes walking around blindly
with dead eyes following orders not
knowing what they do not caring you mean
like Democrats all the actors coming up
now get residuals and have strong one of
the strongest pension packages of any
union in any industry so at the time
Reagan was reviled by everybody for this
deal he made but in retrospect the deal
actually was great for Hollywood great
for the actors great for the industry
saved all these movies from oblivion and
makes Reagan look although he wasn't the
only one involved in the deal he was sag
had a lot of important people he was the
one who understood how to make this work
how to keep peace how to keep people
together negotiators for both sides
expressed satisfaction with the contract
and the belief that it's fair and
equitable and relieved a stable
labor-management relationship Barry
Goldwater's
campaigning for president falling off
the platform drunk at the end of every
speech and they know he's not going
anywhere so they hold an informal
meeting at Reagan's house of people like
Annenberg and and all the biggies that
were his friends and big Republicans up
in Beverly Hills
and they're sitting around saying who
can we get to help Barry Goldwater's
image and that's sitting around and they
see Reagan's smiling at the end of the
table shaking it and they say wait a
minute and that's what my book is so
everything that follows that wait a
minute
you know you know he becomes governor
two years after a bold war two losses
twelve years later he's president and
floats into history as this this great
leader and it really all comes out of
his inability to get work as an actor
his failed career as an actor that leads
him to his - politic well judging from
the applause I take it that you are a
performer
that kind of a performance